faze clan didn't start in cs go they're
playing this trade perfectly and sure
enough double team phase takes umg at
one point the team wasn't even sure they
would be able to enter the scene we got
to figure out how to make the money to
buy this team now because in the next
six months a year this team's gonna be
worth like four or five million dollars
once they did their hands-off approach
at times led the team to disarray the
team is just constantly slapping
different band-aids on the problem and
hoping it works but throughout all the
roster changes and a heartbreaking
defeat in one of the closest major grand
finals ever played the team finally
secured what they were fighting for all
along he's not done
away
[Applause]
[Music]
although counter-strike global offensive
was also a first-person shooter it was a
far cry from the ground sliding quick
knifing and sometimes jetpack employing
call of duty that faze was known for cs
go had grown steadily since its 2012
release and the in-person events were
becoming bigger and more elaborate plus
the release of weapon skins and the arms
deal update made cs even more popular
among casual audiences faze clan saw
potential in the growing cs scene and
knew they needed to act fast if they
wanted in as faze clan founder bank
stated in the bad news podcast in 2020
so my brain like i just we gotta finesse
it we gotta figure out how to make the
money to buy this team now because in
the next six months a year this team's
gonna be worth like four or five million
dollars and we're not gonna be able to
get into this game which in our heads we
need to get in this game faze decided
buying g2 esports's roster was their
best option to enter cs go but the price
tag was daunting so we came up with this
idea with these kids i came up with this
idea for um a different way to do it and
we branded it the right way and
my motivation for doing it actually was
at the time we weren't making enough
money to buy a cs go team all in the uh
the venture was gonna cost us like a
million dollars and we definitely did
not have anything close to that the idea
mentioned in that clip was cs go skin
gambling something that was everywhere
in 2015 and 2016. in that same podcast
banks said that they went to antigua to
get their gambling license and once the
site was online he said it was raking in
200 000
a day that is until valve saw the legal
peril of allowing his game skins to be
used as gambling chips and issued cease
and desist orders to the biggest sites
including cs go wild the site faze was
involved with yeah we were out there and
ran this website for a few months and
then the whatever it was all regulated
and shut down we were the only ones who
were doing it legitimate so we shut our
[ __ ] down and there's still people who
are doing it making crazy money while
banks seem to take some credit for the
site's creation in 2020 he had
previously denied owning it in 2016
characterizing the relationship as faze
agreeing to promote the site in exchange
for money the site's apparent owner
gaiji backed up this characterization in
a 2016 twit longer once concerns first
arose and the incorporation documents
apparently did not list banks as an
owner but promote the site faze did
including very suspicious video from
phase adapt that saw money mysteriously
added to their cs go wild account dude i
don't even know what the [ __ ] just
happened i lost but he lost but he got
money whether banks or anyone else at
faze owned part of the site the money
they earned was a part of how they
scraped together the seven hundred
thousand dollars they needed for their
first ever cs go roster but almost
immediately after signing to faze clan
the roster's performance declined not
sure if jw hadn't i think he did and oh
fox misses the key shawn all of mice is
gonna do it eliminating fate something
clearly had to change and they earmarked
the perfect candidate for that finn
kerrigan anderson who had been cast out
of astralis face came with an incredible
good offer saying you can build your own
team here there is
only one player we want to be in the lab
in the future and that is rain so we
want to build this team around you and
reign the danish german igl was a great
fit for faze he was a talented
strategist and caller and had a history
of getting the best from his players a
lot of igls out there can read what is
probably the best overall strategy
moment to moment but what i think
kerrigan does is he has emotional
capacity he can actually tell when his
teammates are in a mood where they're
going to be aggressive on their own or
they're going to be more passive on
their own so he knows what sort of
initiatives need to be taken and he
knows how to make it easy for his
teammates to
execute all that and alongside kiyoshima
alu azee and rayne the team's results
improved nearly instantaneously one on
two they're trying to make it up to the
side and that is it ladies and gentlemen
faze are gonna be moving on into the
semi-finals knocking out virtus pro but
after a poor performance at the atlanta
major faze knew that they had to change
things up az was shipped off to north
and into his place stepped nico
considered by many to be one of the
game's greatest ever riflers yeah i
think we always at some point knew we're
going to get nico like that was the
whole goal of this team that becoming
that good that nico would actually
change the lineup because he needed one
big superstar that could bring us home
some trophies we can build around many
players but we always need one you can
rely on like kerrigan nico was still
seeking his first major win but beyond
that the two players were very different
kerrigan the cunning in-game leader with
a read for every situation while nico
seven years his junior was known for
taking apart the enemy with precision
rifle work that made it look easy they
gonna have a kid so he's got a lot of
time to work with you nico on the
outside he gets the one kill comes back
from the noise phrase he wins one more
there's still the thing nico he's gonna
go for it he's gonna try to get the quad
kill oh my god nico again there was the
immediate impact of a roster change one
which frankly gave faze more firepower
than they'd ever had he can do this now
for his side to secure his team into the
finals kerrigan chasing down lucas he
does it carrigan with phase knows one's
in the corner hits it incredible but no
way it's done they take down devices
civics is found and faze clan with all
the tools nico finds dupree and step by
step they are on the verge of getting to
the finals here the face landed this one
kill from nico and there it is
but despite three months of strong
results and the roster earning the
number two spot on hltv's global
rankings faze shocked fans with a
disastrous showing at the krakow major
and it's a long way home for the faze
team that has to be highest expectation
and worst outcome that i've seen in
recent memory as a major it was yet
another example of the inconsistency
that had plagued faze since they entered
cs go and as pro player valda would
characterize it years later on the hltv
confirmed podcast it wasn't because the
players weren't talented when you play
the
the style that faze does i think you
need a lot of confidence because you get
a lot of duels it's a lot of dry peaks a
lot of contact plays like symbol fix um
so if you're not
hitting your absolute best individual
level i think you're gonna have a rough
time but adding more firepower had
worked before at least for a little
while so in the weeks after the major
faze clan broke out the checkbook and
signed two of the biggest names in
counter-strike you look at this roster
and you have three of the five players
were in the conversation for the best
player in the world at some point all of
meister definitely being the best player
in the world in 2015 a guardian when he
was in his peak form also in
conversation and nico has always been
around especially since he joined phase
and had some actually good results with
the team played on the big stage what
faze now had was almost immediately
labeled a super team but the roster came
together with little practice time
before dreamhack masters malmo and that
had consequences i think face seriously
dropped the ball on that last map they
had multiple
opportunities to close that game out to
have an even even bigger lead and even a
bigger advantage and they just
failed miserably i know they've only
been together for a very short period of
time they haven't had a lot of time to
practice i want to make a nice broad
statement here i don't think this phase
is going to be anywhere near as
successful as the previous iteration
with keo and alu but instead of raiding
the hotel room minibar and taking in the
sites in sweden the team hit the
practice room and drilled down on how
exactly they would play together so
before the tournament started we didn't
have that much practice and i think one
of the mistakes i did as in game leader
was believing that the new lineup would
fit into the map we had
we ended up playing
five different maps and two of them was
nuke and we lost both of them which was
the reason why we went out
so we went back and look at the mistakes
and and
quickly realized that that nuke doesn't
fit us right now so we cut that from the
map pool and once the team figured
things out fans were treated to some
truly incredible moments
all in at one position at guardian makes
it just nicer to find the flash
[Applause]
and nico fittingly gets the last kill
let's face dominate new york in 2017 in
the barclays center all the way through
this tournament phase are going to
pounce they know that they can push on
to this site that there were two players
there for astralis the flash is in it's
good olefmeister takes down dupreeh now
they know where the remaining players
are coming from and it is inevitable it
is over zip nick's down to five hp and
it's not gonna be enough 16-7 win faze
have done it they are your e-league
champions four versus two doing more
damage leaving oscar with a ump he's
gonna pick up a rifle surely going past
the connector area this is the end of
the line for mousesports phase after a
massive festive three
shut down the dreams desires of mouse
sports and take the championship it was
a golden age for the team one that had
fans convinced that a major win was
within their reach but when it came to
the boston major despite making it to
the grand finals they couldn't make it
happen guardian waits
patiently as cloud9 sets the push up oh
oh this happens they made
major champions
it's not like faze fell off a cliff in
2018 it was more of a gentle slope with
olaf in and out of the roster
inconsistency reigned in the back half
of the year jw finally silenced it but
it's just guardian and an old mob
and olaf gets paid back by his old team
fanatic has done it rumors even surfaced
that kerrigan wasn't calling in game and
that nico had taken over the
responsibility it's sounding like nico
might be leading that at the moment is
that true firstly
uh no it's still like
i don't know we're trying something new
so you don't want to tell me too much
about that no no no no
that's absolutely fine i won't delve
into more details but we just heard the
communication was slightly different and
so in that sense it is true
no comments okay no comment at all until
finally it wasn't kerrigan's team to
build anymore this did seem inevitable
from like the point where they decided
that like oh niko is just gonna igl now
sometimes maybe who can tell no one
knows
um i feel like when you reach that point
within a team then it's it's obvious
that uh your igl's days are numbered by
the end of 2019 the roster was frankly
in the worst position ever in the team's
history sitting at 21st ranked globally
with a revolving door of players trying
to find a combination that would work
surely it's impossible a mac 10 for neo
versus three can he get around the
corner he can't do it renegades take it
they survive and they eliminate faith
clan from the major and not only work
but work consistently because again faze
did have some triumphs that year but
what little consistency the roster could
find on lan was about to be tossed away
along with lands as a whole while they
got off to a decent start during the
online era the phase roster of this
period began to slip against the game's
best and rpk and sharks left
on the other side a little bit of a
molotov they're gonna come flying right
through into rpk and he'll take them
down in 1614 as vitality bring down face
and for a superstar in their prime that
wasn't good enough so nico left the
organization in october joining g2
esports faze's roster was overhauled
adding firepower by swapping out kirby
for twists but it didn't solve the
leadership problem that had seemingly
plagued them for a while he has a kit
and he has a smoke and olof has to leave
now he's gonna make a bunch of noise
he's gonna get that kill he's gonna put
the smoke on top of bomb and no not like
this you are kidding me navi finish like
this
and so they turn to a familiar face i
know the face guys behind me with
organization i've been trusting for a
lot of time i know they trusted me to
come back to to steal the ship in the
right direction and that's what i'm
doing but while some fans might have
been happy to see him back the so-called
kerrigan effect didn't hit immediately
dexter wants to take the peak and as the
swing comes in twist is good for one
they can't get more its mouth sports is
taken away and it'll be faze clan
eliminated last place from the dreamhack
master spring with coldzera benched and
olofmeister set to step back in the boys
on the hltv confirmed podcast had plenty
to say about fades of struggles are we
expecting anything different from faze
they've gone here you go boys we'll give
you a shitload of money we'll take that
two million in sticker money that comes
through every now and again that it gets
put in the game we'll probably use that
to recycle and you guys can be
self-sufficient do whatever you want
look at like neo with dren like
cold there bmas for a little while kyobi
for a little while uh the twist is only
just rejoined robin's come back as a
coach like the team is just constantly
slapping different band-aids on the
problem and hoping it works the roster
fell to their worst ever ranking in
phases history 39th carrick just
charging through the smoke they know
it's over and so do we finishing it with
style looking for the no scope it's
finished off and that's 16. narpy once
more under kerrigan's leadership faze
started their climb but after a
disappointing 11th place finish at the
stockholm major it was time for another
roster change no doubt natural dejection
on that side kerrigan has not moved he
is not unpacking his gear he is just
looking with disbelief in january 2021
olofmeister stepped aside for robs the
rising star who had even applied to faze
clan as a young man in 2014. okay hello
my teams i am roxanne this is my
baseline uh recruitment challenge
response powered by g field and
everything changed axel up through the
window robs has heard something rob's
nose
[Applause]
there since the beginning was rain can't
collect the low hp rain is on the case
and he will do what his teammate could
not all three for rain starts off with
the damage from twists and it's phase on
six brokie had continued to improve
becoming a dangerous offer in his own
right but look the utility usage and
broke he still takes one oh he's got
more he takes two
they tried to get past him but instead
they get blasted and reigns down here to
support so you know okay drops and
twists brought the heat with the rifle
ops is in a huge amount of trouble he's
gonna try and take matters into his own
hands couldn't find the second shot fast
enough but jax he drops in
and if fans were worried about
consistency then the team's victory at
katowice with jks as a stand-in showed
that there was a system it was
kerrigan's system and it was working
broke he's still here oh they lined up
he's actually hit one plus two he did
damage that's gonna drop them down it's
all one hunter and it's all over twist
with the final care and phase finally
stays finally on the stage and counted
it will take a championship and you can
see what it means to kerrigan faze went
from their own absolute rock bottom to
the number one ranked team in less than
a year blinded a little bit but surely
he's going to come back for it all of
faze ready to fight there's the flash
bang broke he's got one more and there's
rain faze have done it and with the pgl
major just around the corner the timing
couldn't have been better now that they
get those two steps closer do they just
want to take this they're going to press
hard into the pit and twist oh my god
with a quick flick of his wand they're
all gone this attack's already crossed
but he's too scoped in
broken okay
and this guy simply does
[Applause]
[Applause]
away faze clan's win at antwerp was a
historic moment for counter-strike all i
wanted in my life was wanted to make
history that an international team
wanted me to envy
but if faze dropped off after winning cs
go's biggest prize they wouldn't be the
first team to do so and any long time
fan could tell you that consistency had
always been an issue with a win at iem
cologne faze could solidify their legacy
and by defeating their grand final
opponents navi the would-be conquerors
of this era kerrigan and his crew would
undoubtedly start their own the pressure
was on no turns around perfecto gone
they're all there
[Applause]
in one magazine concerns the sound is
there the spray is two he's got a second
ak and he hits bin off the bomb they
have to run him down simples posted
twist you've got no hope
no way but perfecto a good bullet nine
hp the first is provided there's no way
there's no smoke brokey just has to
click and we're going to overtime as
much as faze fought tooth and nail to
claw their way back into the series navi
found a way to slam the door shut he's
baited him in they can't find him twist
distracted if he could just do it again
he's on it and he's tapping it rob's
nervous in the big stage
but against their own history and the
odds stacked against them faze found the
confidence to kick the door down simple
solo a glock will do brokey can he come
up clutch against perfecto
looking
[Applause]
these backs
[Applause]
surely he can't hold his nerve in
another impossible clutch three members
of phase they won't let this go they
will not go quietly
all of the rounds
all of the maps
that face cloud complete the triple
after winning one of the greatest grand
finals the game had ever seen faze clan
secured their place as the true kings of
counter-strike you're champions
[Applause]
clan
the team achieved the impossible all
while trusting their players as
professionals to find their own path to
glory that player-led approach may have
been pure call of duty but the result
changed counter-strike forever
thanks for watching if you want more
content like this then hit the sub
button and ring the notification bell
for unique bite size videos you won't
find anywhere else hit up our twitter
instagram facebook and tick tock
you